bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous on vient de le voir la province du
panchir veut résister aux talibans avec
à sa tête le fils du commandant massoud
mais aussi le vice-président afghan
peuvent-ils organiser une véritable
résistance
pour l'instant c'est effectivement ça a
été relayée par sergueï lavrov il faut
relativiser parce qu'on n'est pas dans
la situation
des années 90 2000 où effectivement il y
avait eu un une forte résistance du père
que feu le commandant massoud mais la
situation n'est pas la même aujourd'hui
malheureusement pour son fils c'est pas
une question de légitimité parce qu'il
est l'héritier de son père sa légitimité
pas en cause mais la réalité sur le
terrain est différente aujourd'hui la
vallée du panjshir est une sorte
d'enclavé alors certes qui n'est pas
disposé à rendre les armes mais à la
différence des années 90 2000 c'est qu'à
l'époque avait une cantine une certaine
influence surtout sur le nord du pays
avec la proximité du tadjikistan voisin
or aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas parce
que les talibans ont réussi à mettre la
main sur le nord ce qui est tout à fait
inédit et donc ça induit que ben d'une
certaine manière la vallée du panjshir
se retrouve isolé pour l'instant et il
n'y a pas d'autres foyers de résistance
potentielle armés il y en aura peut-être
mais pour l'instant y en a pas donc en
termes militaires c'est s'est pour
l'instant extrêmement relatifs même s'il
par ailleurs il ya une résistance
sociologique dans les villes on l'a vu
avec le
drapeau revendiquer de l'ancien de
l'ancienne république donc il ya quelque
chose qui se passe mais il faut pas
surévaluer en termes militaires la
résistance en question dans la vallée du
panjshir par rapport à la mainmise des
talibans sur l'ensemble du reste du
territoire justement le fils du
commandant massoud a demandé aux états
unis armes et munitions est ce que les
états unis vont répondre à cette demande
ben justement c'est compliqué par
rapport à la configuration actuelle dans
la mesure où
donner des armes c'est potentiellement
alimenter une forme de guerre civile
mécaniquement avec un succès
qui n'est pas assurée par rapport aux
fournisseurs d'armes en question pour la
raison que j'évoquais précédemment à
savoir que la vallée du panjshir et est
une enclave territoriales mais
finalement très isolée par rapport au
reste du pays et et c'est ça le vrai
défi pour le fils du commandant massoud
kiné qui n'est pas un combattant comme
son père même s'il est il allé
légitimité que lui a transmise son père
il a effectivement le soutien d'un
moulin installé le l'ancien
vice-président enfin le vice-président
puisqu'il se revendique comme telle à
par rapport à la constitution il est
clair qu'il est le président par intérim
du fait de la fuite d'achraf rani mais
la réalité du terrain est tout autre
c'est le problème est d'ailleurs le même
amour la salle et a évoqué la
possibilité de négocier avec les
talibans pour justement que la forme du
régime ne soit pas imposé à la
population afghane mais on voit bien que
la logique de la résistance armée pour
l'instant est
relativement sujette à caution est-ce
que ce qui fera défaut également c'est
la stratégie militaire on voit que ça a
été le cas pour l'armée afghane face aux
talibans
oui alors il ya effectivement des
éléments largan qui a rejoint l'en qui
ont rejoint la classe les forces
spéciales on sait pas d'ailleurs où est
le
général sami sadak qui venez d'être
nommé sur la plaie pour les forces
spéciales s'il est dans l'enclavé
également donc il ya effectivement des
une partie des d'éléments de l'armée
afghane qui ce qu'ils se sont dit
dégoûté par la reddition de leurs
commandants ou dire même de de ahmad
masood justement mais encore une fois
pour l'instant numériquement c'est très
réduit donc on peut pas présager de ce
que ça peut donner par la suite même si
l'esprit de résistance et bien là et il
renvoie directement à celui qui avait
été celui de son père évidemment dans
les années 90 2 mais pourquoi les
talibans n'ont jamais réussi à conquérir
ce territoire est ce que on peut
imaginer que ce sera aussi leur prochain
objectif
ah ben c'est certain on le souhait des
talibans mais il ya une configuration du
relief
géographique qui évidemment profite très
largement
à l'esprit de résistance justement de 2
du fils du commandant massoud et puis et
puis à la galerie la dimension éthique
j'ai évoqué la dimension
tadjik qui est très très forte
évidemment alors que les talibans sont
plutôt majoritairement des pachtouns
même s'ils ont réussi justement à a
envoyé dans le nord lors de leur blitz
une partie des troupes qui qui qui
avaient des tadjiks et c'était ça la
nouveauté c'est pour ça qu'ils ont pu
prendre le nord de cette manière là donc
il ya des contradictions qui sont pas
levés et qui sont en faveur justement de
damen massoud compte tenu de la
configuration actuelle qui évidemment
est très largement favorable ou pouvoir
taliban une dernière question david
rigoulet roze est ce que vous croyez à
un changement d'attitude de la part des
talibans qui essaye d'être un peu plus
diplomate visiblement
ils essaient inde est un peu plus
diplomate mais manifestement c'est pas
c'est pas forcément couronnée de succès
d'autant que tous les tous les
témoignages qui remontent sont
extrêmement inquiétant que ça soit à
l'endroit des femmes ou des journalistes
on a appris qu'il ya une traque avec
délice un rapport de l'onu qui fait
mention évidemment il ya discours
l'affichage et puis à la réalité
derrière le voile si j'ose dire qui est
très très préoccupante avec une traque
effectivement de tous ceux qui ont
travaillé avec les occidentaux d
assassinat et donc d'une certaine
manière cette politique de communication
connaît assez rapidement ses limites ça
va être un problème à gérer pour les
talibans notamment par rapport à une
potentielle reconnaissance
internationale qui est leur obsession et
le j'allais dire que le moyen de
pression ça sera celui là d'ailleurs on
voit bien qu'il ya beaucoup
d'hésitations
compris la russie qui relayait justement
l'esprit de résistance dans la vallée du
panjshir les russes sont pas forcément
pressés de reconnaître un régime taliban
même si tout le monde est obligé de
discuter avec eux d'une manière ou d'une
autre merci beaucoup pour tout ces
précisions d'avis tu rigoles héros je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la revue orient stratégique merci à
vous